it's been less than two weeks since the
statewide eviction moratorium ended
and thousands across southern nevada
could soon lose their homes
thank you so much for joining us tonight
for this special edition of eight news
now
i'm sasha loftis now our local legal aid
center is stepping in to help and offer
assistance to anyone who needs it
eight news now reporter victoria saha
was at one of their pop-up events today
she has the story from west las vegas
dozens of residents walked in through
the west las vegas library
to find any sort of answers that can
help them keep a roof over their head
i was told in southern nevada up to 150
thousand residents are facing eviction
after the state moratorium ended
on june first numbers from the legal aid
center of southern nevada puts nearly
300
thousand nevada residents at risk of
losing their home
kimberly cummings is one of the many
residents desperate for a solution
late nights crying i have two children
so
it's been devastating the single mom of
two lost her job in april of 2020. she
says her landlord didn't waste any time
giving her an eviction notice
after the state eviction moratorium
ended this month
i'm still looking for work you know
that's never stopped
um however i have been with my two
children and like i said it's literally
just me
so we're you know parents that are
between that rock you know
that rock and a hard place what do we do
the rental assistance program did help
for a bit but she still owes money to
her landlord
money that she doesn't have the pandemic
has been so
hard i'm sorry which is exactly why the
legal aid center of southern nevada
stepped in
offering free legal advice to make sure
tenants know what steps to take we've
seen eight thousand fourteen thousand
dollars in rent
families who are really excited to kind
of go you know
start up life again go back into the
world but this
owed rent is sort of hanging over them
pena says if tenants are faced with an
eviction notice the first step is to
apply for the rental assistance program
then find a mediator for your case as
for cummings
saturday's event gave her hope and
bought her some time
i see some sort of light at the end of
the time
if you're a resident facing eviction
help is still available
you can just go to the civil help self
law center where you can find
free legal aid reporting from west las
vegas victoria saha
8 news now the federal eviction
moratorium ends july
1st but the legal aid center says
tenants should not wait for that date to
get help